let's get back to the real world now now
that we've talked about separating
things out let's talk about what
separation of concerns specifically
means for writing applications we can
separate our code into a few
fundamentally different pieces in this
course we'll refer to them as MV and O
Model View and octopus octopus you asked
yes we have Larry the octopus to help us
out now let me tell you a little bit
about Larry
now Larry really dislikes disorganized
code actually Larry hates disorganized
code so much that Larry has decided to
do something about it Larry separates
our concerns now what does that actually
mean
well no matter what the size of the
application programmers like to organize
everything in a few buckets let's talk
about them one by one first the view
this is all the stuff the user sees and
interacts with that includes Dom
elements input elements buttons and
images basically this is the user's
interface to your application both for
giving your application data and for
reading data
now speaking of data here in the model
this is where all of the data is stored
that includes data from the server and
from the user
now the model and the view are connected
specifically by our octopus our octopus
is what provides the separation of
concerns that we so desperately need
when we're building applications now you
can think of the octopus as the thing
that holds things together but also
keeps them separate enough to allow
changes in individual pieces without
upsetting the rest in other words I can
change my view here without disturbing
my model or I can change the way I'm
storing my data without disturbing my
view over here if you search around the
web you'll find all kinds of acronyms
like MVC mvvm and the P and M V asterisk
they stand for a Model View controller
model view viewmodel Model View
presenter or model view whatever
fundamentally the c vm p and asterisk
are all solving the same problem
separating our model from our view now
you'll see all kinds of discussion
online about how different these all are
from each other and in what ways but all
of those discussions are assuming you
already know that they're basically the
same thing
so we'll worry about the differences
later and for now we'll consider these
all versions of the same thing and we
will name them octopus